tout de suite mesdames et messieurs
l'équipe qui va jouer avec nous
présentation aujourd'hui que je suis
prothésiste dentaire et ma mère bonjour
je m'appelle enora j'ai trente trois ans
et j'ai arrêté de boire depuis trois ans
bonjour je suis gérard louvin 42 ans est
champion dutil a vu en deux ans bonjour
je m'appelle isabelle tu temps et j'ai
un mari qui m'entretiendrai je vais bien
jouer pour une association
bonjour je m'appelle gilles j'ai 49 ans
je chante et je danse comme personne et
tant mieux d'ailleurs
bonjour jean michel paris les finalistes
zinc que j'ai un gros 6 y est j'ai la
faiblesse de croire
[Rires]
bonjour je m'appelle valérie et j'ai
deux passions le babyliss et la
littérature
bonjour je m'appelle cyril j'ai 20 ans
et j'ai deux passions le pakistan le
frisbee gilles verdez compléter ces
paroles de daft punk around the world et
fleuves sexy
[Rires]
hainaut et jean-luc parce que c'est une
gare c'est un salon cosy les ans michel
parce que gilles j'ai déjà sauvé cyril
gilles et jean michel parce que c'est ce
qu'aurait fait toute personne sensée
s'agit tout d'abord de gilles verdez
vous nous quittez gilles vous êtes le
meilleur
le deuxième qui va se traîner la honte
dans les couloirs de des huit pour les
deux prochains mois s'appelle le jean
michel vous nous quittez merci bonsoir